im bayerischen freilassing nutzt das
bundesamt für migration und flüchtlinge
dieses ehemalige möbellager als
registrierungsstelle aber die zahl der
flüchtlinge ist seit jahren stark
zurückgegangen
hier ist fast nichts mehr los trotzdem
wird das gebäude rund um die uhr bewacht
24 wachleute sichern wir seit jahren
eine leere halle
kostenpunkt sagenhafte 2,64 millionen
euro pro jahr
das ist unmöglich dass in und summen die
da ausgegeben werden ist hier nichts und
vor allem diese kröte ist die huk ganzen
tag ins verweigerten und lädt doch ich
weiß nicht was die da wir wollen die
mais- oder weil sie nicht also wird das
geld daraus leider wird das ist schon
brutal
ich sehe eigentlich immer jemanden da
vorabend hat mich das oft fragt was die
machen anfang 2016 als täglich tausende
flüchtlinge über die grenze kommen wird
vom bamf ihr eine stelle eingerichtet um
die ankommenden zu registrieren
da die sogenannte balkanroute aber
längst dicht ist kommt so gut wie keiner
mehr an
in den ersten drei wochen dieses jahres
kamen gerade mal elf personen
doch das ehemalige möbellager wird
weiterhin bewacht als legear das gold
der bundesbank im zweischichtbetrieb
stehen sich die wachleute die beine in
den bauch an jeder gebäudeecke
security-mitarbeiter 14 wachleute am tag
und 10 in der nacht auch beim
bayerischen flüchtlingsrat hält man die
generalstabsmäßige bewachung für
absolute geldverschwendung das geld was
da verpulvert wird das lässt sich
sicherlich bei der integration von
flüchtlingen wo alles zusammen
gestrichen wird sehr viel besser
einsetzen da wird geld in den wind
geschossen das ist völliger wahnsinn das
bundesamt wollte uns nicht in der halle
drehen lassen und sich auch nicht vor
der kamera äußern
mitte der woche teilt uns dass damit
grundsätzlich prüft das bundesamt stetig
sein standortkonzept in abhängigkeit
sich verändernder zugangszahlen von
geflüchteten bitte haben sie jedoch
verständnis dass sich das bundesamt
nicht zu überlegungen bezüglich
einzelner standorte äußert die
überlegungen der bürger zum bewachung
irrsinn sind dagegen sehr deutlich der
felix hat die worte mir fallen 1000
andere sachen ein die sinnvoller wären
absolute verschwendung steuerzahlergeld
dass diese türe die weiter hier sinnlos
ihre runden dreht hat den steuerzahler
allein im januar wieder satte 220.000
euro gekostet